Fergie is single and unleashes her best
work yet plus three of the biggest
revelations from Lady gaga
[Music]
hey friends welcome to the daily Denny
it is Friday and we've got a special
fall music preview for you later in the
show but first I've got to stand for
Fergie her visual album double Duchess
is out today her first solo record in 11
years and the new soundtrack to my
weekend at the track I have a repeat is
on Shantae which surprise surprise her
son Axl sings the opening lyrics in for
you told et's Kelty night how the
special cameos came to be I remember
bringing home on shantae I'm going okay
and then he starts I'm chime dinging
come on and I'm going your kid says to
in French I don't know something just
sparked this little heartfelt mommy
pride moment and I just put the phone on
the side
[Music]
you just posted a little teaser you
offered the visual experience featuring
miss Kendall Jenner tell us about that
it's on the family cuz Kim you know of
course it did on milf and I've just
known the girls whole family for such a
long time through different years of our
lives don't we had this kind of random
moment at Coachella
she was lip-synching to a song and I
remember thinking wow she's got like an
inner pop star inside of her and so she
really got to kind of come out and play
a bunch of different characters and just
kind of get her little diva on Fergie is
no stranger to turning famous faces into
music video stars remember this one gave
you his big break - and big girls don't
cry
do you watch this as a know he was on
heroes and he was you know big a heart
throb and yes I do watch this is us I
got kidding me I do live on this planet
it was super fun
shooting that video because I got to eat
out have some of the fun that Josh gets
to have on his movies and but of course
I was totally just nervous about the
whole thing I didn't I didn't know how
to make out for camera I just had to
tell him was he a good teacher he was so
great I bet you was Fergie Berg okay we
have barber sit down with Fergie up now
on et online.com and tonight on ET all
right everybody is talking about Lady
Gaga's Netflix documentary that began
streaming today let me tell you she put
it all out there and here are three of
her most candid moments from the film
first she gives insight into why she and
Taylor Kinney called off their
engagement she believes it could have
been connected to her landing the lead
role and Bradley Cooper's remake of a
star is born the movie it's like a
turnover
this is the third time a heartbroken
late then she also takes on her feud
with Madonna you'll remember in 2012
match claimed Gaga style was a
simplistic copy of her own so the thing
with Look Me in Madonna for example is
that I admired her always and I still
admire her no matter what she might
think of me no I do yeah the only thing
that really bothers me about her is that
I'm Italian from New York you know so
like if I got a problem with somebody
I'm gonna tear face but no matter how
much respect I have for her as a
performer I could never wrap my head
around the fact that she wouldn't look
me in the eye and tell me that I was
reductive that is what we call spilling
the tea folks Gaga keeps it real in this
whole thing and she even lets cameras in
on her doctor visits as she struggles to
combat her debilitating chronic pain
watch what happens when her hip locked
as she prepares for the Superbowl
halftime show
I just think about other people that I
can't it may be something like this
letter struggling to figure out what it
is and they don't have the quick money
to help somebody help them like I don't
know what I'd do if I didn't have
everybody here to help me what the hell
would I do
you would have never known that was
going on and that's just a taste of what
you'll see Lady gaga 5 foot 2 is
streaming now on netflix alright guys
it's Friday and in lieu of a new music
Friday playlist we're gonna hit you with
fall's biggest music offerings for that
and more please welcome our resident
music music expert Sophie Chalet see so
much good tunes I'm so excited I know
I'm bringing my playlist and this wall
there is a showdown of the divas
absolutely now you talked about Fergie's
she just dropped double duchess today
which I am so excited to listen to the
whole thing next week though Miley Cyrus
is releasing younger now which is the
follow-up to bangers and and the dead
pets face on this one though she's
really going back to basics it's much
more stripped-down and she's been really
promising to deliver kind of a return to
her country roots she has a song with
her godmother Dolly Parton which is so
awesome I'm so here for this Miley
evolution but she does have some stiff
competition because I know Demi Lovato
releases her album on the same day tell
me you love me right but I think there's
room for everybody
I can sow and Shania is out that day -
oh god so much music and I mean there
better be room for all these divas there
are so many great women releasing music
right now including Kelly Clarkson her
highly anticipated album the meaning of
life is set to release very soon she
says this is the album she's always
wanted to make it's the first one not
under her American Idol contract so we
can expect a lot of soulful pop songs on
this record it's out officially October
27 well what's so funny because as fate
would have it Kelly's also joining the
voice next season as a coach so she's
badly and Blake Shelton both on the
charts and on TV he's got a new album
coming out as well he sure does Blake
just announced that his eleventh studio
album called Texoma Shore it's been a
labor of love for the Oklahoma native
and he drops that one on November 3rd ok
we can't talk about new albums coming
out this year without mentioning of
course Taylor Swift Queen Taylor what
can we expect the reputation while she's
already showing off a fiery new side of
herself lyrically and sonically it's a
totally different side I think look what
you made me do was to say the least it's
a 15 track album it also promises to
deliver new twists on those catchy love
songs that made her a star
thank goodness cuz long gone are those
teenage angsty love songs from Taylor
and I'm just hoping for more shade in
working
I'm sorry I can happen lots of shade I
think I think we can expect that so that
drops on November 10 right yes November
10 awesome and you know I'm a country
girl so I got a show love to my fave
Dustin Lynch his current album current
mood is out right now I actually invited
Dustin here to our studio we played a
little game of emojis easily my hardest
hit hitting interval yet just gonna
throw it out there you can catch that on
my youtube series it's called certified
country and it is up right now it really
is a lot of fun so you guys definitely
got it make sure you watch that baseball
the scoop so we're ready for foam music
thanks girls yeah we'll see ya are you
guys thanks for watching all week long
we'll be back on Monday with a fresh
dose of the daily Denney so until then
be sure to subscribe to et's youtube
channel and have a good weekend
everybody
yeah we made it t G ah